European Union ministers responsible for
energy policy aim this week to agree on
new rules to make the use of biofuels in
the EU more sustainable and so help cut
greenhouse gas emissions the council
wants to finalize its position on so
called indirect land-use change this is
when farmland is used to produce
biofuels leading to food or feed being
grown in other areas like forests which
results in more carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere the aim is to minimize the
environmental impact of indirect land
use and encourage more advanced biofuels
onto the market also on the agenda the
ministers are set to endorse a report on
progress made toward completing Europe's
internal energy market by next year's
target days the report addresses aspects
like the development of energy
infrastructure ensuring investments
energy efficiency and pricing the
council is also likely to endorse a
second report on the external dimension
of EU energy policy it covers
developments in the global energy
landscape in recent years progress made
in EU policies in this domain and looks
at ways to strengthen them